whoa
okay
it's valentine's day it's valentine's
day we're a couple
we're not a married couple the other
couple's married okay yeah
and if you couldn't tell i'm having a
baby
do you have like boobs noodles i mean a
little
what really and so my current craving is
for mac and cheese
and buzzfeed was nice enough to send us
what i assume is normal mac and cheese
oh no i'm sorry
no candy flavor
a flavor boost no that will turn your
bowl of noodles into a sweet
pink macaroni and cheesy treat
that's disgusting no you don't know
i feel like the flavors are not gonna
arrive at the same time it's just going
to be like
we have them fine now step one boil
water
six cups in a medium saucepan and i like
pretend to stir
ew don't put your food do we have like a
freak
don't put you can pretend to stir later
when there's really something in there
like don't just
my pregnancy brain is telling me this is
gonna be really good why would you eat
that's not how you eat mac and cheese
why did you just eat it dry
so now we add the mac and cheese major
flashbacks to like being a kid i think i
ate mac and cheese like once a week
oh [ __ ]
almost back away so now i'm stirring so
that things don't stick to the bottom
because someone has to step two
drain drain should we have saved the
pasta water
well this is buzzfeed it's not going to
eat
step 3 add margin or butter milk
cheese sauce mix mix well we're using
oat milk by the way because that's what
we have
and if this is awful we can't blame
ourselves and not
the supplier oh no we're definitely
blaming craft
you're like putting me asleep how slowly
you're staying i'm doing a good job
add a full packet of candy flavor
seasoning so i can't believe this but we
are
putting it in addition to the cheese
i mean honestly like maybe it's good
okay guys
i'm gonna prep this into some bowls and
then
uh alicia and i will meet you back on
our couch i'm so nervous to try at night
i think we should feed each other a
noodle
whoa
it doesn't ruin the deliciousness of the
mac and cheese and that's
like it's like actually kind of good i
could honestly eat this whole thing
it still tastes like mac and cheese to
me but just like
with a sweet after kick i don't like it
is it savory is it cheesy is it sweet we
don't know
i'm definitely gonna eat this little
bowl i'm almost done
i i'm going to eat all of it and that's
just the truth
you got one on the table i'll eat that
one too
clean bowl club same glow club did we
mention we're both lactose intolerant
yeah i'm sure
[Music]
you